>> Bret: JOHN ROBERTS DOWN THE
ROAD HERE, THANK YOU.
SOUTH KOREA'S NEWS AGENCY SAYS
DIPLOMACY IS NOW AT A CROSSROADS
BETWEEN THE U.S. AND
NORTH KOREA.
LET'S CHECK IN ON THE MOOD THERE
AFTER THE HASTY END TO.
SENIOR FOREIGN AFFAIRS
CORRESPONDENT IS IN SEOUL,
SOUTH KOREA, .
>> IT WAS NOT THE RESULT OF THE
REGION WAS LOOKING FOR.
FOLKS WATCHED AS PRESIDENT TRUMP
AND KIM JONG UN WALKED AWAY FROM
THE SUMMIT WITHOUT A DEAL.
THE SOUTH KOREAN GOVERNMENT
EXPRESSED ITS REGRETS >> >> I
EXPRESSED ITS REGRETS >> >> T
EXPRESSED ITS REGRETS >> >> S
IMPORTANT THAT THEY DID NOT
REACH A COMPLETE AGREEMENT AND T
REACH A COMPLETE AGREEMENT AND D
REACH A COMPLETE AGREEMENT AND Y
REACH A COMPLETE AGREEMENT AND S
REACH A COMPLETE AGREEMENT AND M
REACH A COMPLETE AGREEMENT AND I
REACH A COMPLETE AGREEMENT AND T
MEETING.
>> A POSSIBLE END OF THE KOREAN
WAR DECLARATION.
POSSIBLY A PLANNED VISIT TO
SEOUL, SOUTH KOREA, BY CAPTURING
ON FOLLOWING HIS TRIP TO THE
NORTH.
ON THE PHONE WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP HE WAS TOLD THE
DIALOGUE BETWEEN THE U.S. AND
NORTH KOREA WOULD CONTINUE AND A
FREEZE ON ITS MISSILE LAUNCHERS
AND NUCLEAR TESTING WOULD
REMAIN.
ALONG WITH A DISPUTE AMONG
SANCTIONS, HE WAS NOT WILLING TO
GO FAR ENOUGH TO SATISFY THE
U.S.
THAT WORRIES NORTH KOREAN ALLIE
ALLIES.
>> WE HOPE THE DEMOCRATIC PEOPLE
IN THE UNITED STATES WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK TOGETHER TO
PROMOTE THE DENUCLEARIZATION OF
THE PENINSULA.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS BEEN TRYING
TO COAX HIS NORTH KOREAN PARTNER
INTO GIVING UP HIS NUKES BY
CITING THE ECONOMIC SUCCESS OF
REGIONAL NEIGHBORS LIKE VIETNAM.
ANALYSTS BELIEVE KIM JONG UN IS
DETERMINED TO MODERNIZE HIS
BACKWARD COUNTRY, SOME SAY HE
NEEDS HIS ARSENAL TO FEEL SECURE
NO MATTER HOW RICH NORTH KOREANS
BECOME.
>> THEY CANNOT BE RICH.
DEAD PEOPLE CAN'T BE RICH.
>> HE NEEDS HAS NUCLEAR WEAPONS
FOR HIS PERSONAL AND POLITICAL
GAME.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP REPORTEDLY
ASKED SOUTH KOREAN
PRESIDENT MOON TO ONCE AGAIN ACT
AS MEDIATOR BETWEEN THE
UNITED STATES AND NORTH KOREA.